psychopharmaka drängen zu suizidgedanken
mhh 370 gefunden wetter zyklen auf pluto
das sind nur drei der fünf themen heute
in den klicks und top five news riesiger
stammbaum fast 23 millionen lebewesen
das war sie hier seht ist ein stammbaum
ja tatsächlich ein stammbaum der 23
millionen lebewesen vereint es ist der
wohl größte stammbaum der bisher
veröffentlicht wurde zitat dieses der
erste ernsthafte versuch alle punkte zu
verbinden und zu einem ganzen
zusammenzufügen
so können bremsten von der duke
universität in durham im fachmagazin
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences stellten forscher ihr
gigantisches werk vor
in über zehn jahren wurden circa 7.500
stammbäume in wissenschaftlicher absicht
kreiert einen solchen gab es jedoch noch
nie zitat vor 25 jahren noch hielt man
es für unmöglich einen so umfassenden
stammbaum zu erstellen berichtete dafür
sollte es von der university of florida
was geschieht wenn zwei schwarze löcher
kollidieren
gute frage die antwort könnte die
menschheit in 100.000 jahren erwarten
im vergleich zu den 3 5 milliarden
jahren die bereits seit der entstehung
der erde vergangen sind ist das zwar
keine lange zeitspanne für die in der
heutigen zeit arbeiten forscher aber
schon
wissenschaftler der new yorker
columbia-universität schrieben in der
fachzeitschrift nature über eine
mögliche kollision zweier gewaltiger
schwarzen löcher astronomischer ort des
geschehens das sternbild jungfrau ein
schwarzes loch fliegt mit also fliegt
dort mit 22.000 kilometern pro sekunde
um ein anderes
bis die beiden dann tatsächlich
miteinander kollidieren würden noch
circa 100.000 jahre vergehen experten
glauben jedoch daran ähnliche
konstellation in der weiten ferne finden
zu können
medikamente gegen suizidgedanken führen
zu suizidgedanken paroxetin und die
gremien sind zwei psychopharmaka die
beide in der schusslinie von kritik
entstehen wenn man der studie die im
fachmagazin british medical journal
erschienen das glauben schenkt dann
geschah das wohl nicht ganz grundlos die
aus amerika und großbritannien
stammenden wissenschaftler kamen auf ein
ungewöhnliches resultat die medikamente
paroxetin und die prämien würden nicht
nur nicht wirklich wirkt
sondern auch noch mehr als ungünstigen
nebenwirkungen mit sich bringen sowohl
paroxetin also in die prämie wird bei
starken depressiven erkrankungen
verschrieben
häufiges symptom einer depression
suizidgedanken eine medikamentöse
behandlung und paroxetin würde jedoch
nicht dafür sorgen dass die patienten
keine suizidgedanken mehr haben oder
diese zumindest vermindert auftreten
paroxetin würde sozusagen das gegenteil
bewirken
so zieht gedanken
verhaltensauffälligkeiten würden nach
der einnahme von paroxetin verstärkt
auftreten bei ihm die prämien könne eine
störung des herzrhythmus auftreten
da die wissenschaftler nicht aus
deutschland kommen fragt ihr euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich wie es hier in
deutschland mit diesen medikamenten
aussieht in deutschland wird vor den
nebenwirkungen des paroxetin im
beipackzettel gewarnt vor einiger zeit
berichteten wir darüber vor neun jahren
machte sich die weltraumsonde nie
horizon auf den weg ins all
die sonne kam dem planeten pluto so nahe
dass sie völlig neue aufnahmen machen
konnte
sie fotografierte die oberfläche und
wertete seine atmosphäre aus über
bluetooth wissen die wissenschaftler
derzeit noch nicht besonders viel
mit den neuen daten über pluto und
dessen atmosphäre erhoffen sich die
forscher zeugnis sie wollen wissen
welcher konstitution unser sonnensystem
vor über 4 5 milliarden jahren war die
ersten bilder haben wir damals schon
gesehen jetzt gibt es neue bilder auf
den bildern sieht man große stickstoff
nebelschwaden zitat abgesehen davon dass
es optisch atemberaubend ist sind diese
tief liegenden dunstschleier ein hinweis
darauf dass sich das wetter auf dem blut
von tagen zu tagen ändert wie auf der
erde
sowohl grandi von l'oreal observatorium
wie auf der erde
genau das war das stichwort haben wir
menschen mehreren milliarden kilometern
entfernung ein ort gefunden der solch
einzigartige parallel zu unserem
lebensraum auf zeigt spannende frage
emh 370 flugzeug endlich gefunden nein
leider nicht aber experten kamen der
boeing 777 einen großen schritt näher
spezielle computerprogramme und analysen
lautendes forschern vom kieler
helmholtz-zentrum für ozeanforschung in
die vergangenheit zu reisen einem
simulationsverfahren stellten sie
partikel bewegungen auf dem wasser nach
um herauszufinden woher gefundenen teile
stammen könnten und wo dann das flugzeug
abgestürzt sein könnte ihm gelang erst
16 monate zurück zu rechnen
ergebnis die südküste von der insel java
indonesien wird in frage kommen zitat
weitere wrackteile werden notwendig um
präzisere aussagen treffen zu können so
arne biastoch habt ihr euch schon einmal
gedanken zum absturz ort von dem flug
emh 370 gemacht wo glaubt ihr könnte das
verschollene flugzeug glichen lasst uns
mal ein paar theorien dazu unten in den
kommentaren sammeln
zum blog kommt ihr hier oben unter
diesem und dann wird ihr euch noch ein
schönes wochenende und bis dahin